it's time to tell my story it seems like
I was born to struggle after a while I
guess I just lost hope that's when my
hair started falling out I'm gonna help
you
[Music]
you bet and so did my confidence maybe I
could say you're proud of it I don't
think
sales is for you colored women will do
anything to look like me even if deep
down they know they can't I can let you
keep beating up on yourself via from now
on Oh doing my own hair make my own hair
gorilla come on Missy I don't take
orders no mo Lincoln freed me 40 years
back that's why I'm on pay and that's
why you my favorite daughter-in-law
let's talk about ham they put us down
tell us will it make us feel ugly
wonderful hair leads to wonderful
opportunities
you sure are lucky you can come the
critics which is why I won't open on
factor there's such a thing that's grown
too fast we live in a man's foot it's
just not our place I didn't come here to
make sandwiches I came here to do
business
oh no you won't do now sir we need a
plan B I'm not going back to long we
don't all made sacrifices you won't do
what's best for this trend yeah is
beauty here in this power damn Sarah how
big you want to be B's Carnegie Ford and
Rockefeller put together
we got to work harder
be smarter
[Music]
and dream big
you